schools across the country are starting
to ban homework elementary school
students have an average of around four
and a half hours of homework a week
while high schoolers get an average of
about seven and a half hours the
National Institute of Mental Health says
more than thirty percent of teenagers
experience some kind of anxiety and
homework is a major contributing factor
Darby Fox is a child and adolescent
Family Therapist good morning how are
you good
so is this about learning or is it about
anxiety this idea of getting rid of
homework or reducing I think the current
thing about getting rid of homework is
about anxiety and trying to reduce that
it should be about learning we should be
able to hit a medium is this a way to
handle it though Darby to just ban
homework altogether and what is a right
amount of homework no it's it's swinging
too far it's like a ultimate reaction
there is a point to homework mm-hmm and
the right amount really is
age-appropriate
so very young kids really sometimes they
like the idea that they have something
industrious to do at home and there's no
harm in that
but they need time to just play and
explore and become kind of curious as we
get older fourth grade you can have 45
minutes an hour up in through high
school two and a half hours what is is
appropriate three hours but schools have
really taken it way too far did this
happen I think it started with our whole
race to get amazing resumes the best
test score gets them into school right
colleges what do I need to put on this
so I could get to the best college but
that has escalated almost directly with
mental health problems anxiety
depression and so much of this is busy
work though I mean that seems to be some
of the complaint that I'm hearing at
least and we do so many segments on the
need for children to be doing sports to
be socializing with their friends a lot
of parents say there's just not enough
time in the day are those factors as
well those are important factors and it
should be thought about as a supplement
not some supplement to what they learn
in school sometimes there is merit in
repeating something or experiencing it
front way or a different venue that we
learn better that way that's how our
brains take it in but I don't know that
I would say necessarily more time for a
sport or another scheduled activity what
I'd really love to see is more time for
kids to have nothing to do unstructured
time so that they have to figure it out
on their own and that's the most
important thing that they should be
exploring how do you feel about parent
participation in homework parents should
guide they don't need to be first grade
it's pretty fun to do the projects and
you want to color it inside the lines
but I think it's more important to think
about if they can't manage it on their
own in a small amount of time and that's
part of the task is how do I manage this
what's enough and then when can I move
on that's it that's important to learn
but parents involvement and over
involvement is an issue and what should
parents do Darvey if they see their kids
are just totally overwhelmed either by
that time or the kind of homework they
have if they're really overwhelmed they
should let the school know the teachers
and if there's not an appropriate
response follow it to the next level is
it the principal or whoever is the next
in command usually that might issue that
might alarmist there's some kind of
learning disability or a processing
problem if it's really overwhelming or
the teachers are just simply giving too
much work yeah and it may also be a good
opportunity to establish more of a
relationship with the teacher right
right right
these are all great tips thank you so
much thanks for having me